LINE-UP, GARRY GALLEY, NUMBER
55HE
CORNER.LAST VISIT.
IN FACT THEYLLIAM NYLANDER DUMP.
AFTER DOWN THE LINE-UP BUT
HE'S GOT LINES HE WANTS TO KEEP
INTACT, KEEP KERFOOT ON THE
UGH CENTRE WATCHING
HIM SENDS IT TO THE NET, THAT'S
DEFLECTED WIDE BY MATTHEWS.HE PK
BUT PLAYED AWAY FROM HIM BY
SEVERSON.E, HE
HERE'S ENGVALL KNOCKED OFF BY
SUBBAN.
CHOPPED AT IT, LYUBUSHKIN THERE,
AND
UNAVOIDABLE.
LYUBUSHKIN IS IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE TEAM WINNING FACEOFFS, AND
>> Garry: OH, I THINK IT'SHAT RT
GOING TO TAKE A HALF A DOZEN OR
SO GAMES BEFORE YOU REALLYY
>> Garry: I THINK INSTEAD OF
TROYING TO THROW IT AROUND
THE OUTSIDE AND UH-UH, THE LEAFS
A NICE JOB OF WAY, MISSES
IT AND THAT COMES TO THE NET AND
YOU'VE GOT HOLL
IN OR EXCUSE ME, MATTHEWS.
AROUND IT GOES TO THE CLOSE IN E
FIRST PERIOD ON A NICE PASS PLAY
WITH MATTHEWS, BUT
IT OFF, UP AHEAD, BREAK FOR
BLACKWELL!
AND HE WAS C BY THE LEAFS,
MARNER TO BUNTING KNOCKED OFFMI.
AS FRONT, RIGHT
ON TO THE STICK OFFT AND HE'LL D
AND DIDN'T TRACK THAT RIGHT
AWAY.
HUGHES SO DANGEROUS, HE CUTS ON
A DIME AS HE TRIES T MARNER UP N
UP AND THE LEAFS GOT A BREAK.
HERE GOES ENGVALL.
PIERRE ENGVALL TO THE
PENALTY, YOU CAN'T BURN ALL YOUR
SETS.
YOU BRING